Matt Hancock the health secretary saying  there are now 53 deaths caused by  coronavirus in this country that's up  from 35 let's have a listen to what the  health secretary announced mr. speaker  the corona virus pandemic is the most  serious public health emergency that our  nation has faced for a generation our  goal is to protect life our actions have  meant that the spread of the virus has  been slowed in the UK and I want to pay  tribute to the officials of public  health England and the NHS for their  exemplary approach to contact tracing  and their work so far however the  disease is now accelerating and 53  people have sadly now died our hearts  across this whole house go out to their  families  [Music]  you